[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
en juin 2014 le groupe armé état
islamique capture la ville de mossoul en
irak et déclare l'instauration d'un
califat des milliers d'irakiens fui
l'arrivée de dèche
[Musique]
pour le géant suédois des
télécommunications ericsson
pas question quitter l'irak mais il ya
un prix à payer pour l'entreprise et
pour ses sous traitants
dames je n'en a pas ou tard
lmh a lié les mains dans le dos et il
m'a recouvert la tête avec un foulard
noir
ils voulaient de l'argent vous venez
travailler sur notre territoire voici ce
que vous devez payer
on n'a pas payé un pot de vin un
policier ou un bureaucrate ordinaire
on ne payait sa à une organisation que
nos gouvernements ont déclaré terrorisme
une fuite de documents confidentiels
obtenus par le consortium international
des journalistes d' enquête est partagée
avec radio canada révèle comment
ericsson et des sous traitants se sont
livré à la corruption
et aurait versé des pots de vin qui ont
abouti entre les mains de serge
les multinationale suédoise ericsson est
bien présent chez nous où il joue un
rôle clé dans notre infrastructure
téléphonique
dans l'attende une décision d'ottawa qui
pourrait bannir le fabricant chinois
huawei ericsson a décroché des contrats
avec la plupart des entreprises de
téléphonie du canada pour leur fournir
l'équipement des réseaux 5 g
[Musique]
au fil des ans ericsson a reçu des
millions de dollars en subventions du
québec et madame marois était là parce
qu'il ya investissements subvention de
10 millions
mais les retombées économiques ne se
sont pas toujours matérialiser eric sehn
a fermé son centre de données de
vaudreuil en 2017 à peine dix mois après
son entrée en service
ericsson brasse des affaires à l'échelle
mondiale y compris au moyen orient où un
alléchant marché est apparue en irak
après la chute de saddam hussein
tout était à réaliser la vente ou les
infrastructures téléphoniques en irak
était à non pas à rebâtir mais a bâti et
donc nos jeux financiers étaient énormes
ericsson a décroché de lucratifs
contrats avec des agences
gouvernementales et les fournisseurs de
services de téléphonie mais l'irak est
un paradis de la corruption
selon un rapport confidentiel d'ericsson
obtenu par le consortium des
journalistes d' enquête certains leurs
employés sous traitants auraient versé
des pots-de-vin commis de la fraude
détourné des fonds est blanchi de
l'argent entre 2011 et 2010 9 l'irak
après l'invasion américaine était l'un
des pays les plus corrompus au monde
si vous allez investir dans un contexte
où le système est régulée par la
corruption vous ne pouvez pas dire sauf
si vous êtes très naïf que vous allez
arriver là bas et ne pas fonctionner et
selon les pratiques locales
la situation s'est corsée pour ericsson
lorsque le groupe armé état islamique a
pris contrôle du nord de l'irak des
centaines de tours de télécommunications
était désormais sur le territoire
contrôlé par des shs et les employés qui
devaient être déployées sur le terrain
avaient peur de sortir
[Musique]
ericsson a ordonné un employé dans le c
sous traitants un ingénieur de 25 ans
d'aller déposer en personne une lettre à
des dirigeants des ch demandant la
permission que ses équipes puissent
poursuivre leur travail
cet ingénieur nommé afin s'est confié à
nos collègues la télévision allemande
ndr à visage couvert car il craint de
faire l'objet de représailles
ils m'ont dit tu la porte au siège de
dèche à mossoul valeur portée et
regarder leurs réactions
il accepte vous êtes couverts vous
continuez votre boulot s'ils refusent
reprendre documents et revient on
trouvera une autre solution
mais après avoir livré la lettre des
membres de dèche l'ont kidnappé ligoté
et cagoulés
ils m'ont embarqué à l'arrière j'étais
assis entre deux hommes armés de
kalachnikov
ses ravisseurs l'ont amenée sur le bords
du tigre et lui ont ordonné d'appeler
son gestionnaire une fois la
communication établie ils ont menacé de
faire exploser les bureaux d'ericsson et
ont exigé le paiement de millions de
dollars
je ne comprenais rien je me disais qu'à
n'importe quel moment il pourrait mettre
fin à la discussion mettre une balle
dans la tête et me jeter dans le fleuve
le gestionnaire d'ericsson a raccroché
la ligne les militants armés ont ensuite
ramené afin de chez lui en lui
interdisant de quitter sa résidence sous
peine de mort
c'est le projet d'ericsson ce sont eux
qui exerçait des pressions pour que ça
avance le travail ne devait jamais
s'arrêter peu importe le prix
c'est sûr que dans la balance le bien
être de leurs employés était moins lourd
que les profits chef intègre
aurait dû dire bah si c'est comme ça que
ça va marcher sur ce territoire on va
mettre nos affaires entre parenthèses
à peine un mois plus tard des chats
décapité le journaliste américain james
forley dans une vidéo mise en ligne sur
internet qui a semé l'effroi au sein de
la communauté internationale
là c'est réellement un manque de
jugement que de poursuivre les affaires
en irak vous allez aussi
mettre à disposition de d'âge une
infrastructure de communication dèche a
fait une utilisation massive est plutôt
entre guillemets sophistiqués des
réseaux sociaux des moyens de
communication modernes c'était au coeur
de leur machine de propagande
selon la fuite ericsson a employé un
stratagème afin d'éviter que son
équipement soit livrée en empruntant les
autoroutes principales où se trouvaient
des postes douaniers irakien
mais en voulant éviter de payer les
douanes les sous traitants d'ericsson
ont dû payer des shs le moyen de les
contourner et est de trouver de
nouvelles routes ou les agents des
douanes
et à thiennes ne pouvait pas les
attraper et c'est comme ça qu'ericsson
un concert payer des groupes armés qui
contrôlait des territoires et ses
territoires échappée de fêtes ou
contrôle des autorités irakiennes et
parmi ce territoire là et bien il y
avait un territoire qui qui qui
appartient quitté contrôlée par partage
ericsson a refusé d'accorder une
entrevue au consortium des journalistes
d' enquête en réponse à nos questions la
compagnie a admis dans un communiqué
qu'il y a eu des inconduites liés à la
corruption en irak mais qu'aucun de ses
employés n'a directement payer des ch
elle dit vouloir réexaminer son enquête
tout ceci ce qui s'est passé en irak
n'était pas étranger à la haute
hiérarchie de l'entreprise du moins la
vice-présidence affaires du moyen-orient
donc la théorie de la pomme pourrait il
faudrait la remplacer par la théorie du
verger pourri
ericsson a déjà été accusé par les
autorités américaines de corruption dans
d'autres pays en 2019 la multinationale
suédoise a signé une entente à l'amiable
avec le département de la justice des
états unis elle a dû payer une amende
d'1 milliard de dollars et a promis de
changer ses pratiques et certains disent
et une taxe à la corruption et saf ça
semble pas mettre les freins sur
l'actuelle la pratique de corrompent les
agents publics à l'étranger bout je
pense que tant et aussi longtemps que la
dissuasion sera pas plus forte en europe
de la difficulté à s'en sortir
jusqu'à maintenant ericsson a réussi à
éviter toutes sanctions criminelles mais
à la lumière de nos révélations le
département de la justice américain
vient d'accuser la multinationale
d'avoir violé son entente à l'amiable
parce qu'elle ne lui a pas divulguer
suffisamment les détails de ces sales
affaires en irak
[Musique]